if Kirsten has got any sense his entire
election campaign by which I mean from
now on will be to make people think am I
better off than I was four years ago or
even 13 years ago most people will say
no and although I think elections in
this country are not quite so much based
on the state of the economies are in
America it is the economy stupid
generally I think that there's much more
at stake here and you can always or you
could I think probably still camera rely
on labor to make the odd strategic
mistake I mean why is kierstama banging
on about Europe he spent the last three
years not banging on about Europe quite
successfully but he's now made people in
the red wall seats remember that he was
the one that wanted a second referendum
and wanted more integration and I do not
understand the logic of what he's been
doing over the last few weeks